Christopher Nolan's newest movie leaves
out one big element of the physicist
story and for good reason the film is
just as much about the scientists and
its world-changing work as it is about
the atomic bomb itself which he and his
team tediously developed during the
second world war its existence looms
largely over the entire story but we
only see it explode once during the
Trinity test the US Army's first
detonation of a nuclear weapon that
means that the two most famous nuclear
explosions in history the attacks on
Hiroshima and Nagasaki are never shown
on screen as Nolan revealed in a
post-screening q a session it's no
oversight that moviegoers don't witness
the bombing of the two cities in his
biopic given that Oppenheimer is a
film's main human subject most of the
story unfolds from his perspective so
the director didn't feel that it quite
made sense to cover the bombing of Japan
we know so much more than he did at the
time he learned about the bobbings of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki on the radio the
same as the rest of the world Nolan
added that his film is an interpretation
of the real life story of Oppenheimer
not a documentary or direct reenactment